when I came to Islam and I started
asking hey what about if I sent we made
Toba what if I drove drawing somebody
will you go make it right with that
person that makes sense God can forgive
anything but that makes sense you don't
have to kill anybody you don't have to
kill God or his son is wonderful right
it makes sense all the prophets had one
message believe in God follow the
prophet of your time you're successful
it's not like okay Adam's time you have
to Abraham Moses and then Jesus switches
at all of us now you don't have to
believe in God and you just have to
believe in Jesus that's it and you go to
heaven No Good Deeds